what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are getting into the origin
of Ghost Rider 1 million now really I
call it Ghost Rider 1 million is
technically 1 million BC anyway this is
the origins where you of that character
now here is an important thing to bear
in mind and we talked about this and the
First Avenger story arc - Jason Aaron
did the original it like not really the
original but Avengers vol 1 as part of
Marvel's Fresh Start was a total
upheaval for the origin of all
superheroes on the face of the planet
Earth it was insane like it was it was
massive this was a big change it changed
why the Celestials came it changed what
the Celestials did and it changed how
the genes of humans were meddled with
but what what Jason Aaron's been doing
this entire time is introducing the idea
of an Avengers team that existed
1 million years before the modern day
but it is kind of a cool thing because
what this does is it explains how this
one know this Ghost Rider 1 million came
into existence and how it is that this
character became part of the Avengers
team now what this does is this jump ax
jumps back to the days of early man
that's actually a really really cool
thing basically it's that that kind of
missing link but wouldn't you know
between the time that man was modern
more or less and the time you had eight
so it was kind of like that eight man
that eight man missing link now this is
cool because it's Jason Aaron kind of
tying things into the roots because the
idea of humans genes being modified in
the early days by Celestials that was
eight men and while he's wiped that away
what it has done is it still takes place
in that point in time that missing link
era and so what we end up doing is
picking up with this one guy who doesn't
really have a name and instead he's just
like a pretty young member of his own
group and is exceedingly intelligent and
that causes fear among his people now
the whole idea is a Jason Aaron plays
with this and says this is basically a
tribe that lives in the cave and has
never left the cave they were born into
the cave they stay in the cave and they
never leave that this very primitive
tribe has never left its own environment
and as a result although all the space
outside they refer to as the great white
which of course is basically saying this
is in a wintry area in a much colder
area it's always cold out there and no
one ever goes out there for fear that
they may die but for this troop itself
because of the fact that basically
everything out there is unknown to them
they're terrified of anything different
from themselves and so what they end up
doing is basically casting out those who
are who are perhaps misformed
who or who are deformed when they're
born those who are who aren't strong
enough or even in the case of this child
those were who were too smart anything
that's deemed to be scary is cast out of
pushed away and so in this instance what
is up happening is so I just kind of
shows up here one day and then like
kills some of the members of the tribe
and this leads to him basically being
put in the position of an alpha male
again hitting back to early tribe
culture now this guy basically seizes
control and takes over and so what you
end up getting here is this guy kind of
leading the whole thing but he's
exceedingly smart like he's well-spoken
and that's the big difference between
himself this kid and everybody else this
kid is the first one to learn how to
speak he's the first one to learn
language now we're not told explicitly
how there's really no definitive answer
here but this older guy is much the same
way I mean he's very well-spoken he's
very eloquent and what he talks about
here is the idea that these members of
this kid's tribe who are primitive who
are scared of things that are different
they're essentially cattle like their
prey they serve the purpose of being
consumed by those who were stronger
because they're too honored their too
unintelligent they don't have what it
takes to make it on their own and this
guy kind of shows this by morphing into
a beast of sorts and killing everyone
now as soon as I saw this as soon as I
saw this guy transform and as soon as I
saw the shadow I was like that's the
Windigo it's that and the fact that he
was dressed in all white then I was like
this has to be a Windigo we're in a
wendi-go I think is how some people
pronounce it but like I pronounce it up
Wendigo he had to be a windy up now
those are guys you don't know what that
means windigos made her debut in Marvel
Comics in 1978 with the Incredible Hulk
162 bruise a guy named Hulk Hardy her
and the idea here was at the Incredible
Hulk had stumbled into the Alaskan world
I'm sorry into the Canadian wilderness
and basically like some people were
attached by like a beast in the woods
and you ended up finding out it was this
guy named Paul who was turning into a
Windigo now at the time Steve Englehart
did not really offer any measure of an
explanation that didn't come until 2014
I think it was with amazing x-men number
12 I want to say it was the second
volume but with amazing x-men 12 by
Craig Kyle and Chris Yost and that dealt
with a guy named tar neck and we'll talk
about him here in a second with you know
in the original Steve Englehart stories
all you really had was just like dis
curse that had been laid upon anybody in
a Canadian wilderness by the Elder Gods
and that was it it was this idea that if
a person consumed the flesh of another
human being they would be transformed
into a Windigo and there would be curse
to maintain that for all eternity unless
like the curse was lifted by basically
sacrificing them or something along
those lines I came in rough top my head
but they were just sort of characters
that were thrown in for the purposes say
like here is a thing a hero is do
at the time when the story starts and
that's it but the time 2014 came around
with Craig Holly and Chris y'all
suggesting that what they did is a tide
in the character of sasquatch and what
they said was that the original us can I
can never member his name the original
Sasquatch um when he became his
character he was actually switching
places with a guy named tar neck and tar
neck was the one who had initiated this
curse again no one's really done a whole
lot to really create like a one-shot on
the origin of the windigos because they
don't really matter I mean they're not
really relevant I know there's some
people out there who loved them and I'm
sorry to say that but like they don't
really matter but still this guy
basically lays waste to everything and
simply tells this kid if you want to
know my name come and find me and we'll
go from there now this is when Mephisto
steps in and this is how it always works
those you guys you don't know who who
are new to Marvel Comics who are
stumbling into this video
Mephisto is both the devil and not the
devil in Marvel Comics and I say not the
devil because Satan actually does exist
in Marvel Comics now the way this
character works he's wildly powerful but
Fisto is insanely powerful but he's the
most powerful in his own realm so the
longer he lead the longer he's gone from
the realm of hell the weaker he gets but
what he'll usually do is if there needs
to be like a Ghost Rider or the story
calls for it or something like that will
basically reach out from beyond the
grave essentially they're kind of you
know from his own dimension and he'll
trick a person into becoming the Ghost
Rider and he'll say look if you are
willing to sell your soul to me then
like I will give you everything you want
and it's never usually that blunt right
he won't meet you I mean he won't say
like sell your soul to me who do exactly
what you're doing here well I can give
you the tools for revenge I can help you
achieve this and in the instance where
this kid's freezing is I don't don't you
want to be warm I don't you want to warm
up I can make it so that you never
freeze again it's it's little things
like this it's coming in and sort of
offering himself as a guy that can give
them every wish every desire that they
want to fulfill and then of course you
know we end up finding out if the pack
to the ghost rider and so when he
becomes a ghost rider basically you have
to be released the old ghost riders just
sort of serve this purpose they're
doomed to that role for all eternity but
what ends up happening is that with this
kid being basically met with the powers
of Mephisto the powers of the Ghost
Rider this allows him to go forward now
you know for five years
this kid searches all up and down the
Canadian wilderness looking for this guy
and ultimately manages to find him but
because of the fact that this man hadn't
had basically named this kid ghost
we said like your name from now on his
ghost and then in turn he became the
rider two and two were thrown together
his first names ghost his last name is
Rider now we're not given any indication
that's why ghost riders are called ghost
riders that's just why he has this name
they're called ghost riders because the
name sounds badass that's why they have
that's what they're called ghost riders
because it sounds awesome but still like
you know with Ghost Rider facing off
against against Wendigo it's not a small
thing now usually the important thing to
remember this kids just now learned what
he's capable I mean you'd have to assume
within the last five years his main
focus has been hunting for this guy and
so he hasn't really got you know looked
into doing things like the penis tear he
hasn't really looked into like expanding
his abilities and learning what he's
fully capable of right it's like getting
your paycheck and then running off to
the bank to deposit it you don't really
do anything with an in-between or at
least getting cash and then running off
to the bank to deposit it you don't
really do anything with it in between so
you don't really know what all I can buy
and so with this this situation is the
exact same thing at least that seems to
be the case and it seems to be kind of
what Jason Aaron's running with here now
the other thing to bear in mind here is
that windigos are not just like a
sasquatch type beast that's just that
kind of strong wind egos are strong as
hell like they are they're extremely
strong like they can licking ghosts they
can go pound for pound with the
Incredible Hulk
super strength super speed a healing
factor these things you know windigos
are not by any means like pushovers
they're not fighting what amounts to
like feral wolves and so when you have
this Ghost Rider kid facing off against
this Windigo you basically have a kid
with a new set of powers he doesn't
fully understand that he can kind of use
energy blast here and there facing off
against a guy who's presumably been a
Windigo for who only knows how long I
mean really it's an ageless curse so
you're talking about a guy who could be
a Windigo this guy could've been a woman
to go for like a thousand years you
don't really know how long he's been
this way but like holding his own
against this kid like just totally
wrecking him is pretty damn impressive
mean like this window gets impaled by a
impale by the the woolly mammoth this
kid's been riding on can we all just
take a moment to say bye to acknowledge
this kid has been riding on a wooly
mammoth that blows fire out of its trunk
how badass is that like that's that's
like one of the coolest things ever I
want to see that like right now like I
want to see that in comics right now you
know this mammoth impales this this
Windigo and in the Windigo like grabs a
mammoth throws it over and then falls
over alongside it and that's kind of the
crazy thing because he makes a comment
all survived this whole thing will you
and this kid doesn't know that he would
that's kind of the crazy thing but if he
jumped over he would survive it I mean
he would he would survive the experience
you know his body would be broken all
the pieces but like he would survive it
but what this does is it means that
like this kid says you know he kind of
hears a disembodied voice it tells him
you're not all alone like you're never
you're not by yourself there are people
out there who were just like you and
when this kid turns around he's met by
the arrival of the Phoenix in Odin and
basically this is the reason why he was
brought in because they need him to
fight the Celestials but it's kind of
cool here because what this seems to
indicate is that like he would go on to
understand the full brunt of his powers
what he was truly capable of now
presumably a lot of this would be
learned from from the Phoenix or could
be learned from from Odin we're not sure
because the Ghost Rider stands alone as
it really is kind of cool to get this
origin story to see how this guy came to
be and is pretty interesting I'm
actually really excited I want to read
some stories about like The Avengers 1
million BC so long as it's written by
like Jason Aaron or Craig Kyle Chris
Yost let any of like the top writers at
Marvel at the moment boy I was going
Becky Cloonan I would read the hell out
of an Avengers 1 million by Becky
Cloonan
gonna tell you something man let me clue
nan she was the one who wrote Punisher
before before was his name took over due
Becky Coonans Punisher run was just
stupid good and like dude I'm so sad
they took her off they didn't like a
year ago we to have Becky Cloonan right
Avengers 1 million like we need to have
that done that'll be cool if Jason Aaron
doesn't want to do it then Becky Cloonan
should because like that would be that
actually pretty badass anyway guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comics explain make sure
you guys at the sub button to become
part of the Rob cork you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]